quante volte avete sentito dire una
donna non dovrebbe dire parolacce e
volgare
io credo centinaia di volte e ogni volta
rimango sempre stupita dalla mancanza di
logica della platea
insomma le parolacce non sono sempre
volgari se le dice un uomo vanno bene no
non vanno bene nemmeno se dette da un
uomo ma se ne dice una donna è peggio
non sta bene
delle comiche donne si dice spesso
appunto che siano volgari e che parlino
ha soltanto di cose da donne eppure
nessuno dice mai che i comici uomini
parlano solo di cose da uomini anche se
è così
questo perché vi diamo il maschile come
il default mode lo standard e il
femminile come un'eccezione ma come può
metà della popolazione mondiale essere
un'eccezione
e perché questa eccezione ricordiamolo
formata da metà del genere umano deve
stare mille volte più attenta a quello
che dice a quello che fa e soprattutto a
come si pone
no mi spiace risposte originali non ne
ho l'unica risposta che ho è scontata e
banale ed è tale in quanto vera è una
questione di sessismo ma ogni volta che
faccio notare il sessismo che riempie la
nostra vita eccoli che spuntano tutti a
darmi della femminista isterica ea
cercare di zittirlo perché vedete le
donne non devono dire parolacce non
devono essere volgari ma soprattutto non
devono esprimere opinioni
perché a furia di esprimere opinioni c'è
il rischio di smetterla di essere
un'eccezione
anche se sono diplomata come attrice e
anche se ultimamente mi sto dedicando
più che altro a mio podcast rayman
comedy io sono una stand up comedian
come dicevamo prima in italiano si può
tranquillamente tradurre con faccio la
comica ma noi del settore ci piace
specificare usare un gergo tecnico anche
se ovviamente il pubblico non ha idea di
che cosa stiamo parlando
e questo per me non è stato un percorso
facile quando sono tornata in italia
dopo essermi diplomata in arti
drammatica a new york mi sono ritrovata
nell'ambito dei laboratori comici che
nonostante il nome no non sono dei corsi
di scrittura creativa bensì delle serate
dove dei comici alle prime armi vengono
buttati su un palco spesso davanti a un
pubblico disinteressato e spesso senza
nessun tipo di preparazione
certo queste serate sono supervisionate
da degli organizzatori dai alcuni si
autodefinivano autori anche se non ho
mai visto nessuno di loro scrivere e
mezza parola è però devo dire che questi
autori mi hanno dato dei preziosi
consigli come ad esempio questo clara
questi monologhi che fai in italia non
vanno bene non puoi dire certe cose non
puoi parlare di sesso sul palco
come non si può parlare di sesso sul
palco i comici lo fanno in continuazione
sì i comici ma tu sei una donna giovane
eppure fibra se ti metti a parlare di
sesso sul palco il pubblico pensa ascom
parti non ti ascolta e non ride
ero allibita da questi ragionamenti così
distanti dal mio modo di vedere le cose
insomma non tutti gli uomini sono così
limitati e se anche fosse il pubblico
non è certamente composto unicamente di
uomini etero e donne
esistono donne che vogliono ridere di
certe cose e lo so perché io sono una di
loro
quindi perché questo sembra non
interessare a nessuno
la realtà è la triste realtà è che per
molti di questi organizzatori di serate
di questi autori
il pubblico è formato da uomini etero e
basta le donne non esistono
però questo lo devo dire pur nella
mancanza di lungimiranza
devo dire che queste loro conclusioni si
basavano su un dato assolutamente reale
dopo anni di spettacoli di stand up
comedy devo ammettere che il pubblico e
per la maggioranza maschile le donne pur
tendenzialmente più amanti degli
spettacoli dal vivo sembrano ben poco
interessate alla comicità da donna
estremamente interessata alla comicità
mi sono interrogata spesso sul perché le
mie simili non lo siano
e ci sono diverse teorie c'è la risposta
biologica
secondo cui la comicità è una forma di
aggressione un moderno sostituto della
violenza e in quanto tale dominio
maschile chi la pensa così non ha mai
visto una chat delle mamme
sì lo so questa era una battuta banale
basata su uno stereotipo ma senza un po
di autoironia non andiamo da nessuna
parte soprattutto se si sta parlando di
comicità
poi c'è la risposta sociologica secondo
cui alle bambine viene insegnato sin da
piccolo è fin da piccoli ad essere
gentili ed educate a controllarsi ea non
mettersi in ridicolo mentre invece i
maschi possono fare i buffoni
tranquillamente per tutta la carriera
scolastica e anche oltre
e infine c'è la risposta a terra terra
semplicemente le donne non hanno senso
dell'umorismo è così e basta sono
isteriche e non riescono a farsi una
risata
sarò strana io che ho sempre visto nella
nell'umorismo nell'ironia
qasmo e anche nel famigerato black
humour l'umorismo nero il modo migliore
di alleggerire le tragedie piccole e
grandi che ci circondano e non voglio
oggi venire qui a mettere in dubbio di
essere io quella strana è no però dopo
anni passati a parlare ad un pubblico
prevalentemente maschile c'è stato un
cambiamento radicale nella mia
professione ed ora mi ritrovo a parlare
ad un pubblico a maggioranza femminile
cos'è cambiato
ho iniziato a parlare di omicidi
si da poco più di un anno conduco con
marco jean pierre un altro commedia
crime comedy un podcast di true crime
true crime in italiano sarebbe cronaca
nera è però cronaca nera non sono
altrettanto accattivante quindi diciamo
true crime parliamo di serial killer o
di delitti particolarmente
disturbanti scendendo spesso nei
particolari più morbosi ma evitando di
mantenere un finto tono solenne
nonostante le ricerche certosine e
spesso maniacali che facciamo prima di
ogni puntata ne parliamo come se fossimo
al bar anche facendo uso di black humour
e a volte cadendo nel volgare
insomma tutto quello che dovrebbe far
inorridire le signorine per bene
eppure quasi il 70 per cento delle
nostre ascoltatrici sono donne
ok il numero esatto sarebbe 69 per cento
ma se dico 69 sul palco poi il pubblico
maschile mi si distrae non lo dico io lo
dicono gli autori
quindi forse non è l'umorismo di per sé
a tener lontane le donne forse è il
fatto che quell'umorismo sembri
provenire sempre e comunque da una
prospettiva maschile
spesso se si sta anche quando non lo è
intenzionalmente
quindi invece di limitarci a lamentarci
del sessismo nella comicità che esiste o
addirittura a rifiutare la comicità
forse dovremmo abbracciarla anche noi
e dovremmo soprattutto agire per fare in
modo di renderla più inclusiva questo
credo io non si ottiene facendone una
sterile questione di numeri pretendendo
lo stesso numero di donne e di uomini
trippa chi ne boicottaggio o cancellando
i comici maschile anzi comici maschi
vorrei dire ma supportando attivamente
le umoristiche già esistono sia alle
prime armi sia già affermate ci sono
tanti modi di supportarle possiamo
sostenerle sui social leggere i loro
blog
andare ai loro spettacoli aiutarle a
scrivere di più insomma a fare il
possibile perché queste umorista e
possano crescere come artiste esibirsi
di più scrivere di più e guadagnarsi con
i loro meriti effettivi quello spazio
che troppo spesso viene loro negato da
parte di organizzatori convinti che il
pubblico sia fatto solo di uomini
dimostriamo loro che non è così
non solo a parole non solo con i posti
indignati su facebook ma con i fatti
solo che oggi sono qui a parlare di
donne comicità ecco io vorrei concludere
prendendomi un attimo per parlare anche
degli uomini che finora ho descritto
come dei buontemponi
ho notato una cosa negli ultimi anni
ricevendo tra l'altro continue conferme
sembra che gli uomini intesi come maschi
del genere umano e lo so
questa è una generalizzazione ma
seguitemi tendono ad avere pochissima
autoironia sul loro essere uomini in che
senso
immaginatevi un qualsiasi comico
televisivo è probabile che nel suo
repertorio ci siano diverse battute
sulle donne che non fanno parcheggiare
sulle suocere rompiscatole sulle mogli
spendaccione e il pubblico cosa fa ride
anche le donne
sembra che le donne in genere e sto
dicendo in genere quindi anche poi
esterna generalizzazione non protestino
più di tanto per le battute sessiste
sentono una battuta sessista ci ridono
sopra e finisce lì ecco
quando però si attacca la categoria
maschile soprattutto se a farlo è una
comica donna le cose non vanno tanto
lisce gli uomini questa famosa risata
non se la fanno anzi fanno il broncio
incrociano le braccia protestano
soprattutto adesso che grazie social
network la protesta si può
tranquillamente fare seduti in poltrona
poltrona ovviamente è un eufemismo per
gabinetto
e
[Musica]
vedete quando questi uomini protestano
che cosa dicono
la risposta più comune è è ma noi non
siamo tutti così è noto il man
ma va ma lo sappiamo che non siete tutti
così lo sappiamo le battute si basano
sullo stereotipo non sull'analisi
capillare di ogni persona esistente se
una battuta ti ferisce al punto da farti
sentire in dovere di protestare
forse perché preso fuoco una coda di
paglia che disse perché vedete noi donne
brave a parcheggiare non cerchiamo
ossessivamente di silenziare ogni
battuta che ci dipinge come
dell'incapace alla guida quindi perché
così tanti uomini non riescono a
tollerare la più lieve scalfitura loro
ego
forse è perché non ci sono abituati al
contrario delle donne e allora dico io
invece di considerare la comicità il
crudele regno del maschio etero bianco
ci soppressore di popoli forse come vi
dicevo dovremmo abbracciarla anche noi
donne magari
scherzando proprio su di loro e
scherzare su di loro sarebbe solo per il
loro bene hanno bisogno di abituarsi non
ci sono abituati povere stelle
anni fa venne bloccata per un mese su
facebook che in seguito mi cancello
anche la pagina per una battuta questa
dobbiamo ammetterlo la sindrome
premestruale ci influenza per quei tre
quattro giorni al mese diventiamo
scostanti aggressive rabbiose e
ipersensibile alle critiche praticamente
degli uomini
causa del blocco
incitamento all'odio
odio o di ragazzi era una battuta
una battuta tra l'altro la cui tesi è
stata confermata dal fatto che così
tanti uomini se la siano presa al punto
da segnalarmi in massa
quindi ragazzi veramente fermiamoci un
attimo ma non erano le donne quelle
senza senso dell'umorismo
così non va bene uomini veramente non
fate gli isterici e fatemela una risata
grazie